breaking tonight russian president
vladimir putin telling the west to back
off
this comes amid international concern
over his troop buildup
on the ukraine border here in the u.s
one top military commander says the
chances of nuclear war
are actually increasing national
security correspondent
jennifer griffin tells us about it
tonight from the pentagon
russian president vladimir putin issued
a stark warning to the u.s and nato
during his annual state of the nation
address to parliament
i hope that no one dares to cross the
red line in respect to russia
and we will determine where it is in
each specific case
putin spoke as russia continues a
massive military buildup on the border
with ukraine
new satellite images show dozens of
fighter jets lined up on tarmacs in
southern russia and crimea
top u.s military commanders warned that
new threats facing the u.s
have them seriously worried for the
first time that u.s adversaries
may consider using a nuclear weapon as
the least bad
option the admiral in charge of
america's nuclear arsenal says it's the
first time in history
the u.s has had to deter two nuclear
powers at the same time
russia and china i cannot deter with the
leftovers of the cold war
forever into the future that is a 70
eras weapon system
that i'm going to have to employ against
20 30 level
threats some democrats want to scrap one
leg of the nuclear triad
the 400 ground-based missiles currently
in silos across three states
the head of strategic command says he
needs to replace
not update those 50-year-old minuteman
three missiles
democrats don't like the price tag you
know we're currently spending forty four
and a half billion dollars a year on
nuclear weapons
and i know that stratcom likes spending
that money
but i don't the u.s stopped keeping
nuclear-capable bombers like these b-52s
in louisiana on 24-hour alert in 1991
but admiral richard warns if the u.s
scraps its ground-based missiles
it would have to rely too much on
submarine-launched nukes
under those conditions i would request
to re-alert the bombers
putin boasted today that russia will
have modernized more than 88 percent of
its nuclear weapons by the end of this
year
admiral richards says the u.s hasn't
started
brett jennifer griffin at the pentagon
jennifer thank you